if this virus
could be beaten by round-the-clock
unrelenting care
then it would be done for this is this
is hell
we cannot continue like this we need to
ask people to please
contribute stay home exhausted medics
and terrified patients gasping for life
in sealed off rooms
have the same message for those of us
lucky enough
not to be here i am one of the persons
sometimes i was saying
this is not true this is but no
is it true it can kill you do you
understand people want to get together
you know and see their relatives
this is the result it's all
all ages they're my age or even younger
than me
and there's older people who died for
cohort yes
this is the epicenter of the covet
crisis
a place of miracles i cannot tell you
how
relieved we are how happy we are how
thankful
and unimaginable heartbreak we just sort
out
that we will live and come out of it
i just think it's staggering this has
become a normal way to practice medicine
it just makes everything so much more
difficult
and for awake patients very very scary
when we first arrived in the royal free
hospital last tuesday
intensive care consultant mike spiro was
playing a losing game
of bed spaces there is a limit to the
critical care
capacity in london we're at a situation
within
the whole of london at the moment
whereby we are having to consider
transferring patients out long range
yeah we have to select very carefully
who we move because what we don't want
to do is move someone and then
deteriorate on routes
yeah how far might they have to move at
the moment we're looking at the midlands
the title royal was granted to the free
hospital by queen victoria for its fight
against the cholera epidemic in the
1800s
now nearly every floor of this 12-storey
building is treating patients with covid
he could go into one of the hives side
rooms if um
the operations room records 307 positive
patients on site
over a quarter more than 80 of them are
on ventilators
pressure control will draw it down from
18 to 16 because i think he's waking up
so the tidal volumes are too high
actually we could bring it down
now in normal times this room would be a
recovery ward
for surgery patients it's been adapted
they've doubled the bed numbers
and each specialist itu nurse such as
nicholas
used to offering one-to-one care now has
at least
three patients under their watch i feel
like i want to cry
in many moments i mean i can do my job
properly what's been the toughest
toughest thing for you
well basically i mean a lot of people
are passing away
and you have to keep doing your job when
you have
a gentleman or a lady that is passed
away and is
lying next to you and basically
we just need to keep going and wait for
somebody else to come and take care of
that and
it's horrible my biggest worry is
whether we've got enough staff to get
through the next 24 hours and that's 48
hours
and i think that's the thing that that
keeps me awake at night
this week we had the army yes i saw the
army had arrived
that's right so that's a help oh it's a
huge help
actually everyone is mucking in if not
army medics it's medical students even
surgeons
acting as nurses lucy barker a
consultant from moorfields eye hospital
now clearing airways next to her evelyn
and patricia two therapists who'd
normally work with special needs
children in the community
now putting mittens on a 41 year old
covid patient
to stop her pulling at the tubes thank
you so much for helping
add to that specialists from every
corner of the hospital
offering their expertise everyone has a
role to play because
covert is a multi-system disease
we see kidney issues we see liver issues
we see clocks and we can we see heart
attacks
and and apart from the devastating
effect it can have on the land
then there's another type of care for
those desperate to be at the bedside
on the fourth floor medical student
helen spends all day
face timing patients families so you're
literally kind of going
yeah from patient to patient the ones
who are conscious at least
oh even if they're not conscious but
this was a special moment
the first time nikolai usachi responded
to his loved ones
since early december how long has he
been in intensive care
he's been more than 40 days from the 6th
of december
till now yeah that's that must be
very traumatic time for your family yes
but we never lost hope
we just prayed we thank god and we
prayed again
he's a miracle we just thank to god
on the eighth floor a step down from
intensive care
siddharla yusifi is slowly becoming less
dependent
on the equipment that's helping him to
breathe this is a massive improvement
over the last four days
exactly i appreciate is the end of the
world
apocalypse honestly is the apocalypse
can't breathe yeah
you feel very cold in the brain
in the brain very cold and freezing
and a lot of panic
a lot of panic i was i was feeling the
same is the end
this is really serious you have to take
it serious
i am one of the person who ignored
all the message unless sometimes i was
saying
this is not true this is but no
is it true can kill you
in the basement of the hospital patients
are looked after with the same care as
they were upstairs
we we care for patients they're patients
they're not you know they're still
patients
we treat them as they are but these are
the ones who didn't make it
there is no pacemaker
yeah there is nothing on the face or
ears
it's a bit you know heartbreaking coming
every day to do this
and still have people telling to your
face that this is not real or that this
is the flu
when you open these fridge doors
sometimes you must see some quite
young faces yes yes yes definitely
it's all ages really like uh
we have patients that they're my age or
even younger than me
um and there's older people who died for
coverage
uh yes enough that must shock you when
you when you see that
yeah how do you feel
sometimes it's the hardest i think it's
when you see someone that maybe reminds
you of somebody else that you know
or a familiar name or or a familiar age
you know like you know you think
automatically about your family
or your friends a red asterisk
marks the patience with kovid and this
is by nearly every name
laura too has noticed a change in the
people coming here
the first time we're definitely older
patients but it seems more varied this
time
it seems to be a much wider age group of
patient that we're
getting into our care it's more as if
patients in their 50s and 60s that we're
seeing this time
rather than patients in their 70s 80s
90s like we were the first time
at barnet the royal free sister hospital
covert intake is double that of the
first wave
and the average age coming in is 59 a
decade younger
than first time round here we meet 73
year old tony brown
a key worker lorry driver who delivered
bread
and is now precariously ill how are you
feeling
i absolutely terrible if people
would have taken a lot more care when
this come
out and then ignored it
we wouldn't be in such a mess very bad
nights
very wondering night twice
i went to ring your wife to laura
weren't coming
what do i say linda
oh mister when was the last time you saw
linda
i was too rich to go linda allowed us to
broadcast this interview
which took place on thursday
that is one of the hardest things i'm
sure not being able to see
your wife
i hope everyone though hopefully i will
it's all right now
i don't want anything else
i'm sad to tell you tony didn't make it
he died on friday night
behind glass and warning tape medics in
masks and gowns
are the only company for those fighting
quiet
terrifying battles against a virus that
in the uk
has taken nearly a hundred thousand
lives